[Music]
now I demon scientists bloke
oh hello and welcome to the point and
apologies in advance actually to
everyone over the age of 24 the
following sentence but this Sunday
August 3rd doom 3 is 10 years old so
with all this talk about doom 4 aka doom
a better time to go back and play this
classic and see how it stacks up after a
decade of maturing or rotting first of
all some historical context by the time
its software released doom 3 it had been
almost four years since their previous
release the fantastic quake 3 arena
quake 3 had rewritten the rulebook for
first person games discarding the
campaign mode to focus entirely on arena
combat and there was similar pressure
within gaming circles for doom 3 to do
something as revolutionary right now
it's been 10 years since doom 3 was
released and the same was true then doom
2 was released in September 1994 or less
than 12 months after the release of the
first game so it's fair to say that fans
were anticipating the latest chapter and
though we didn't know it then it
signified the closing of a chapter for
it
in fact when you play Doom 3 today it's
impossible to think about it at sight of
its place within gaming history and that
happens right from the off doom 3 opens
with a shooting free introductory level
which establishes the location and some
story beats this experience is pretty
tried in first-person shooters nowadays
but it was an interesting evolution for
doom a series like most vanilla
first-person games in the 90s that had
you laying waste to enemies almost
immediately though games like System
Shock and other RPG titles at
introductory levels that wasn't until
half-life's classic intro in 1998 that
it became a staple of the genre it's the
old trick of showing you a place on a
normal day so that when the catastrophe
hits you have a context for just how bad
things have gotten
and it's when it all goes wrong that
doom 3 reminds you it's a doom game the
original doom games were quick draw
exercises imps pinky demons and zombie
men would pop up behind walls and ambush
you you were always on your toes that
sounds of him
growling and snorting to be heard all
around almost like they were in your
head when the [__] goes down in June 3
it's a similar experience enemies pop
out of dark corners as your radio is
constantly filled with the haunting
screams of your fellow Marines you
frantically pant across the surface of
the planet watt lights blow out and
terrifying skulls scream through
corridors this is the essence of doom
sure you're fighting zombie soldiers and
evil creatures but unlike enemies in
other games there's something far more
disturbing like the zombies in System
Shock 2 and the ever tangible presence
of show Don the zombies and demons in
doom are far more than just beasts that
see you lesser in the natural order of
things
they feel evil compelled personally to
rip you apart almost visibly angered by
your mere existence and that's a feeling
that doom 3 retains thread its campaign
sadly though your ability to dispatch
these guys means that many of the early
bad guys become cannon fodder pretty
early on the original game got around
this using quantity and this is where
doom 3 ultimately falls short the
original games were corridor crawlers
but they often opened up into wider
areas with hordes of bad guys to kill
doom 3 never really does this and it
makes the spawning points of the enemies
there monster closets incredibly
predictable and variation in combat is
kept to a minimum
in fact it also inhibits you from using
many of the larger weapons as there's a
good chance you're gonna splash damage
yourself into an early grave or at least
the idea that you might stops you from
wanting to use them a bit of a shame as
some of the best moments in the early
games came from unleashing a PFG into a
distant pack of pinky's so why did doom
3 focus on smaller areas well because
ultimately doom 3 was a graphical
showcase when this game came out in 2004
it was the best looking game ever made
period as tight as the areas were they
were incredibly detailed had believable
physics the bad guys were incredibly
well animated and and had some of the
best lighting effects ever seen in games
remember half-life 2 was still a couple
of months away doom 3 attempted to be a
much more atmospheric game than its
predecessors and in some ways it did
achieve this the flashlight could only
be used in sacrifice of holding a weapon
which arced many players but it made
diving into dark areas that much more
tense but if you didn't enjoy it you
could just download the duct-tape mother
with stake a flashlight so you're gone
or take the edge off completely with the
Hello Kitty flashlight I still find this
entire opening sequence
absolutely terrifying in 2014 and the
whole campaign is a little bit longer
than I remembered it's actually around
the 1700 mark and for me personally I'm
not sure what it's like playing this for
the first time but this is like going on
it going to a theme park of nostalgia at
the time I remember being amazed by the
interface on doors and computers
I love the new models for many of the
larger enemies the new terrifying pinky
demon looked and moved incredibly I've
got fond memories of Doom three and so
do it to date it's still their highest
selling game and serves as an inflection
point for both them and the genre doom 3
was a by-the-numbers first-person
shooter that was elevated by a wonderful
engine that made it genuinely
atmospheric for me 2004 marked the end
of the Golden Age of single-player
first-person shooters a number of months
later with the release of half-life 2
and doom 3 surely marked the end of the
Golden Age of its software though a Tech
4 could be seen in games like prey and
brink unreal engine absolutely tranced
them in the third party engine Wars and
with so many big names leaving in
production on some of their biggest
titles were out sourced Raven Software
led development on quake 4 which the
least is said about the better while
enemy territory quake Wars from Splash
Damage never had mainstream success and
remember rage yeah I bet you forgot
about rage its offer are absolutely the
most important name in the history of
first-person game design but it's been a
tough decade for them both themselves
and their various IPs are now under the
stewardship of the thursda softworks
whose management of the most recent
Wolfenstein game developed by machine
games has resulted in arguably the best
Wolfenstein game ever made my hope is
that this latest doom which is currently
only been seen by fans at quake on
behind closed doors and can do something
similar as Wolfenstein but in the
meantime because it's probably going to
be a long time before we actually ever
get to see that for ourselves when I go
back and play Doom 3 for if nothing else
to remind yourself of just how exciting
first-person shooters were a decade ago
and how they didn't have autosave
[Music]
I'll teach you yeah just like crazy
dynamic shadows I jump down there and
see the shadows even better
Jesus at one time with these emphases
you could like basically figured out
that they had like they never fit
through the fire where you were going to
be they always through worries you work
so I feel like they were only put in
you'd like to teach you how to stretch
or remind you at espect look at this
remember this lighting good way for me
I'm trying to show the lighting I like
it's a PDA is my favorite part of the
best doom right now is that instead of
in lieu of using different colored keys
it just using my sight I didn't use I
thought because it's 2040 of PDA and I
think I got the PDA downloading PDA
grand faster I bet he left a wonderful
audio log on I bet he also had access to
a room but I need to go to
[Music]